Speaker 1: Speaking of which, Donald
Trump throwing democracy in the toilet
and flushing it 10 to 15 times at 230 in
the morning, we knew he was up to something
weird in the middle of the night, didn't
we? Donald Trump saying that Carrie Lake
should be installed as the governor
of Arizona. You know, if you go
back and look at the history of, generally
speaking, overwhelmingly the 20th century,
but also to some degree the 21st. And you
look at leaders who were, quote, installed,
it's not a particularly good history. And that is
exactly what Donald Trump is now demanding happen
in the middle of the night. Donald Trump posting
to his platform, truth, social censure. Well,
call it what you want. Quote, massive
numbers of quote and fully capitalized broken
voting machines in Republican districts on
Election Day, capital letters everywhere. None
of them make sense. Mechanics sent in to, quote,
fix them made them worse. Kerry had to be taken
to a Democrat area which was working perfectly to
vote. Now understand that none of that is true.
Her opponent ran the election. This is yet
another criminal voting operation. So obvious,
Carrie Lake should be installed, governor of
Arizona. This is almost as bad as the 2020
presidential election, remember? It's almost as
bad because nobody's the bigger victim than Trump,
which the UN Select Committee refuses to touch
because they know it was capital F fraudulent.
Look at what is happening here this wet from
summer 2020. Well, you know, there might be
problems that Democrats take advantage of because
of mail in voting and early voting. No evidence of
it, but it was a much smaller claim, too. I won.
I won. And they stole it from me in November of
2020. Now to install the loser. Install the loser,
make her the governor, even though she actually
lost. If we win, it's a fair election. If we don't
bring out the pitchforks, demand a new election,
say it's fraud and blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. Now, one of the craziest things about this
is that Kerry Lake is still insisting
that they're going to get this one back.
Now, much like with all of these people, we don't
know to what degree are they grifters? To what
degree are they liars? To what degree are they
victims? I am struggling to believe that Kerry
Lake has even a 1% belief that they are going to
somehow get her to be the governor of Arizona.
And yet she just posted as a reply to Donald
Trump's troth, quote, Arizonans have no faith and
trust in our elections. And what's notable is she
capitalizes. Faith, trust and elections, just like
Trump does. Very weird. She goes on to say, Our
election officials are incompetent or worse. They
have failed us. The fake news ignores our fake
elections and expect us to just, quote, move on.
We won't. America will not survive if we don't
demand election reform. Now, do we think for a
second that Kerry Lake really believes she is
going to be appointed the governor of Arizona,
installed as the governor of Arizona, declared
the winner of the governor of Arizona race?
I am really struggling to believe that. And what
I think is actually going on here is that this
is Kari Lake's continued addition to be Donald
Trump's vice presidential running mate in 2024.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE has made it clear she
wants to be Trump's running mate in 2024. And
Kerry Lake is making it clear as well. And
as I've said before, not all of the people
claiming that 2020 was stolen really believe it.
Some of them say it because they realize that it
is the thing you're supposed to say if you are
showing your allegiance to Donald Trump's team.
And I believe that that is part of
what is going on here as well. If
you believe that Kari Lake believes she
is going to be the governor of Arizona,
let me know in the comments and make
sure you're, of course, subscribed on
YouTube in order to be able to comment at
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.